and we start with breaking news a
convicted murderer is on the Run we've
just learned he's been gone now for days
but the Department of Corrections issued
information earlier today saying the man
who planted a bomb that killed another
man at the Luxor parking garage well he
escaped 8 news now reporter Ryan Matthey
live at the prison where a search is
underway Ryan
now Correctional Center officials first
released this information today just
before two o'clock implying they first
found out about this today now this was
hours after our 8 news now investigators
first broke the story around 11 o'clock
this morning and now just within the
past hour the governor of Nevada
confirming he's been missing since early
this weekend it's this man on your
screen right now he is serving a life
sentence here without the possibility of
parole his name porfidio Duarte Herrera
he was convicted from that killed
another man at the Luxor in oven that
bomb hidden in a coffee cup Correctional
officials determined or at least said
they determined him missing today at 7
this morning and a search began for him
an hour later U.S Marshal Services
described him as armed and dangerous and
are assisting in the search Governor sis
lack saying in a statement quote my
office has ordered the ndoc to conduct
and complete a thorough investigation
into this event as quickly as possible
this kind of security lapse cannot be
permitted and those responsible will be
held accountable the correctional
facility describes him as a medium
security inmate if you see him to call
police immediately